oh welcome to pi data boston's february
2021 meetup
i'm glad to see so many people
interested in these subjects
our topics tonight will be geodata
processing and boat
locating turn out
and and i'll skip around because we did
some of the stuff out of place like
q and a like you want to share that you
want to share the slides sorry about
that
no no no i'll go
share screen
okay is it the share screen option
you don't yeah that should do it
also
[Music]
okay cool
uh are you guys seeing the pi data slide
yes yep awesome
all right uh since you guys already
introduced yourself i'll
jump to the second item you guys are
cool to ask questions at any time
please turn off your microphone and
speak soon
here here are here are different sites
meetup links
please feel free to join sign up
retreat read retweet
and of course re-share on your own
platforms if you're on facebook
or some obscure thing we don't have on
here yet
would definitely be much appreciated
okay why is it not going to the next
thing
okay
i'm checking a little bit of lag on my
part
so anyways pi data boston is a
is a member of the pi data network who
are a
sub project of the num focus
organization
whose code of conduct we all fall under
and
we take serious inclusivity and
non-discrimination
like things like racism and sexism
horrible no-no's we will not will not
tolerate we want to be a friendly
inclusive environment
and we all volunteers are also always
it for organizing going forward
as you can see the online part is the
main
relevant one
and we will
if caesar's ready to go we'll try we'll
move on to him
you ready caesar
all right all right let me
should i just make your co-host i think
so all right
set us as disabled participant screen
sharing
maybe you need to stop sharing all right
[Music]
all right there it is
all right you're the center of focus
caesar
all right can you guys see my screen uh
yes cesar i can see you
i can see and hear you fine awesome
great
uh yeah super excited to be here tonight
presenting about these
uh this is a project that i work a lot
on last year and
a little bit this year as well um i
wanted to introduce myself a little bit
so my name is
hernandez and i had uh i've been working
with data
maybe for the last uh 10 years um
when i started working in there i was at
deloitte working with a lot of financial
data
and then i moved to vista print 2014
where i was working
in the crm team and also in the data
science team
and in 2017 i moved to tripadvisor
working in product analytics
where working so many different projects
but eventually i sort of like started
working mostly on their engineering
projects
and most recently i'm working with the
machine learning team
um yeah and also uh
one of my hobbies is hiking i i enjoy
hiking in winter so you can see here
that during my
all this covet pandemic i actually grew
my beer
and this is how my beer looks when it's
frozen
um yeah so today i want to talk to you
about
uh a project that i work on that i
volunteer my time
to work for uh is uh something that we
named crowdfree for those of you that
don't know what crowdfree
that me is it's basically something that
um basically gives you some ideas
of where uh how like crowded
is a place different places are in a
given place
so funny story to provide some context
so
in february last year um when all covets
started we had a hackathon
and one of the idea was exactly this
was basically i sort of like the main
use scale was like
hey i need to do groceries but i
basically sort of like
completely acquiring quarantine at home
but i need to go to the grocery how do i
know where to go
um during that hackathon we we
i mean we started working with different
uh libraries and we got to do something
pretty cool
uh but i realized that in order for me
to actually
be able to put something like this
together i needed like more help
i'm not a from an engineer i do a lot of
data stuff but not necessarily
from front-end stuff and at the same
time
i real there was a group a trip advisor
which is the company where i work
on that was actually trying to do this
and they actually needed somebody that
could work with data
and i was like okay sweet i can sort of
like
try to bring the help to bring this idea
online and also the same time learning a
lot about like geo data
because in my regular job i actually
don't work with any geo data
i work with a lot of web data but not
necessarily geo data
for those of you that have worked with
geodata you probably know that it's a
it's a quite complex and i'll explain
why
in a second so the main app is it's
basically just looks like this that is
on my screen right now
it's a big map we have the entire united
states
and you can like search for a place you
can move
you can see like densities in different
hours of the day for different places
if you if you click somewhere
you can actually get a histogram of like
how credit
and specific places and you could you
can also get some information about that
place
it's quite simple simple uh in the
back end there is a lot a lot of data
processing
and that's what i want to talk to you
about today
so um at the one thing
uh that we do with crowdfree is that
basically
we what we are doing basically is uh
getting data from cell phone data and
then we aggregate
all that data and then we try to show
that to the user in a way that is
easy to understand so people can make
their own decisions about where to go
and when we started the project uh
sort of like our sketch looks a little
bit like this
um it was uh
something this is what we thought that
it was gonna be and at the end of the
project is this is what it was
um almost everything on the bottom
of this diagram is all data processing
and then almost everything at the top of
this is the front end
application the same way that
we did a lot of different iterations we
also iterated a lot with the
visualization so
in the beginning it looked something
like this on the top right
and then we actually got some
cool maps with heat maps to work and
then finally we got to
what it is today that it looks like this
so again i get to work on uh to talk a
little bit about the data
um the data that we are using that there
are basically three different kind of
line grass data sets that we
consume the first one is places
that we call places and this actually
was donated by safecraft which is a
company that works
with um with geodata
and what they provide to us is every
month they provide a huge
file that contain all the businesses in
the united states
and it contains the polygon information
and get into what the polygon is
but in addition to that data they
provide other metadata that is quite
important about the business like
hours of operations the category of the
place
the address that is important um
and a lot of other different data the
other data set that we consume is open
spaces so
open spaces um it's coming from
open stream maps and this is an open
source
data that you can anybody could get
and it basically gives you parts
information and open spaces
information so if you for instance once
the
polygon that define what the bottom
common is
you can actually get it from this data
set um
as i said before places provide only
businesses but we thought that one of
the cool use cases for this was like
we all need to um recreate and go
outside and we necessarily don't want to
go to businesses and maybe we want to go
to a park
but if we're going to a part like which
park do you go in what place of the park
you want to
enjoy some time outside so
this is one of the other data sources
that we consume and finally
the data that is the massive data that
we receive
is the telemetry data and the telemetry
data is actually provided by two
companies sex mode
and beta set and what this data is is
basically your cell phone
depending on the apps that you have is
capturing a lot of your
signals of your cell phone and then
these companies aggregate this from
multiple different
multiple apps and they sell this data to
other companies
this is how they do like marketing and
in the case of this application this
data was also donated to us
and and we received this data every day
and they give us an update that expands
to 20
between 24 and 48 hours
so what does the polygon data looks like
so the polygon data looks like just like
this so this is a
like one of the records that we received
the polygon data is basically a bunch of
different points that can basically
define
the contour of a given place so
if you have a square you basically just
need four points but
most polygons data is very very
complex and this polygon um
wkt that is a well-known text
representation of
geometry might be massive as i said
before like
so this is quite important because this
basically defined the space of a
business
as as for the telemetry data we
get roughly 5 billion records every day
and the data is quite rich but the data
as well as reach is very duplicated so
depending on the cell phone device that
you have or the app that you have
your cell phone might be capturing up to
a thousand different signals
every single day even if you just have
it you know
you're on your desk and the data is
really rich so we have
stuff like advertiser id that sort of
like define your cell phone
but it contains some of the most
important stuff which is latitude and
longitude that give us sort of like the
exact location of a given place and
something else that is quite important
to our model is a speed
and i explain why speed is important as
well
so the sort of like the summary of what
we really wanted to do
was to do something like this in mind
that you have this placing here that is
defined with the polygon
and you have all these different points
that define where people
are in a given hour so with the polygon
you can actually
get the area of the place and key and
given all the points that are inside you
can actually come up with a score that
is the density of that place on a given
hour
so in this case if we have exactly the
same place
and we have our thing on our 11 on our
thing we have
six different signals that were inside
the polygon and on our 11 we have
four different signals so that tells us
that rela
for that specific polygon relative to
itself
we know that it is more dense at
like 10 a.m that i 11 a.m
so one of the reason why we do density
is because the polygon can be
really big so it's not the same to have
100 people seeing a
really big place like let's say home
depot
that if you have a hundred people in a
tool store that is
small so we basically try to normalize
by the area so that way people can make
inform decision about where to go
depending on how crowded that place
is
in the same way something that we do for
normalization
is that we also normalize depending on
the zip code
so that way people can compare the
similar places or around around the
place where they live
so if we don't do this we get into a
place where
everything in new york for instance is
gonna look crowded
and everything in a place uh you know in
a rural area
is not gonna look crowded um the main
use case is
for people to use this locally to be
like i need to go to the pharmacy or i
need to do groceries or
i want to go to a park so we want to
normalize by the area where they live
so that way when people are like
searching they can actually compare
places around their
locality in an in an easy way
all right so for open spaces
sort of like the process is a little bit
different so imagine that we have
something that is huge
right like let's see my central park in
new york
if if you try to come up with a density
for central park
it's going to look quite low because in
reality
there are only few places especially
like the roads that that cross the
central park that are um that is where
people are located
so something that we did is to use a
library
that was created by uber and it's open
source it's called
h3 and there is a python api that you
can use
and what it gives you is a
hex representation of the of the world
so why hexes is because like it's a
really good compromise between circles
and
squares and they're not going to overlap
with each other
so in this case you can see here that i
don't remember the resolution of this
photo but
i added in here a link so people can
actually
uh find some examples of this you can
actually get different hexes in here so
in mind that you have centra
central square central park um in new
york
you can actually get different hexes for
the entire
central park and they have tried to
calculate the density of those hexes
and once that you have these x's you
basically can treat this the same way
that we treat the places
which is basically just well i have the
polygon information
and then just trying to calculate the
density in there
so i want to give you an example of what
this looks like
so this is um what it looks like for
wolfen square so i used to live in
waltham so i know this place pretty well
um so you can see in here like
everything in here that looks like a
polygon where you can actually see the
shape of the polygon really well
this was uh this is a business or a
place that we get from the places place
but in here we know that this is
actually it's coming from the open space
and the the only reason i know that it's
open space is
well one because it's a park that i know
and second is because the representation
of the data is a little bit different
so you can see in here that we're using
heat map
so that way if i actually want to go to
the park
i can actually tell that
okay on this area here on the top right
of the park there is usually a lot of
more people
at this time of the day on wednesday and
then i can decide to go with my family
to another place
the way that we destroy the data is a
little bit different as well we use heat
maps as well
instead of like hexes because we just
didn't want to show
all the polygons uh uh on top of the
different places so if i go back in here
this is how one of the visualizations
are in the process of how we were like
trying to visualize this it looked a
little bit like this and it's
kind of crowded so we ended up using
heat maps instead of like hexes
all right for the fun part so
i just want to explain so now that you
have some of the context of the data
i just want to give you an idea of the
scale of the data
so i mentioned that we have about around
five billion record for all the signal
data
and again these are points of data at
different times of the day
and for the polygon information we have
around 4.1 million records
from safegraff and about 2 million
records from open space
so one thing that as i explained before
we had a bunch of patterns one of those
parts was amazon
um and they allowed us to use their
entire infrastructure
so we there is this called
database called aws athena which is
pretty cool because
uh what you have your all your metadata
is saving s3
and then you basically build your entire
data set
database on top of s3 and the
engine that athena use is uh similar to
presto
so that way you you can actually use
pretty cool functions that are created
in
presta and the library for geo live
functions is quite
comprehensive one of those is a st
contain
which if you've seen here you can
basically pass two geometries and it's
gonna return true or false
if one if the geometry on the on the
right
is contained on the geometry on the left
so
one example in here in this case you
have this
geometry and this is actually a square
if you see here
there are four points that define a
square and you have this point
zero zero so in this case
i'm not sure but it basically is gonna
give me like oh this point is in this
in this square or it's not however
when uh what we're doing so there are
like
quite big limitations in here so why the
scale of the data so if we're talking
about
five billion record for signals and six
million records for polygons
in order to apply this is basically a
cross joint of data
and once that you join this it's just
massive it's
it's really really big so that's
that's already like that was already a
limitation that we hit early on
the second limitation is that uh geo
functions are very computing
expensive so um
if you try to do this operation you
pretty much are like
no matter the database even aws athena
with
by like trying to like expand the limit
of all that your computing power this is
gonna fail
so we had to come up with different ways
to do this so
one of the first things that we thought
about doing
was you have to partition the data so
since we have
24 of 24 hours of data uh
on a day we thought well let's just
break these 5 billion records
and then just try to process one hour of
the time
so that way we can actually uh maybe
this works and that didn't work so we
had to do something else
so for that we basically use um h3 again
so something that is really cool about
h3 is that
it allows you to get a mapping an index
for a given location
so in this case you can see here that
if i pass to h3 latitude and longitude
and a resolution
and the resolution is basically how big
like how big your
hex is so something like i
right now i'm just guessing but maybe
resolution zero
might be just a massive hex that cover
the entire wall
and the bigger the resolution is the
smaller those x's are
so if you put some something like this
latitude to this logic to this you
basically get something like this
it's just a string that you can use
and if you pass a polygon in this in the
case of wealth and square
and this is the actual like polygon
information
you get an array of different hexes
so why is this important is because now
your joint doesn't really depend
on geo functions that you need to apply
to the data
now if i basically explode this array
i can actually do just an inner join
with this data set
and and and that has like a massive
massive
improvement and it actually made our
life
make the project possible to do and not
only that
is uh the other thing is that as you are
doing this inner john you're also
filtering data so
one thing that we wanted to do is to
make sure that we were not showing
density for people houses so we wanted
to make sure like oh we're selecting
just businesses so
once that you do an inner join of
pre-selected data
you can actually just get rid of
anything that is not a business or a or
a park
the other thing that we did is to dedupe
the data
so as i said before i mentioned that
your signals
your cell phone might be capturing a
bunch of different signals
so um and if you uh
in this representation here if we have
two signals
on the same hour on the same heads we
pro we know it's only one person
so we don't want to um we don't want to
like
show that display super dense just
because some cell phones are just taking
many uh recording many more signals and
so because we have the advertiser like
this
we were able to uh to dedupe the data
so that way something like this at the
end will look a little just like this so
for these two so this that in here the
green one is just the same device it
will just look like one
and the i mentioned before one another
thing that is important is the speed
so if you think about like
well central park in new york or even
boston common
there are some like uh like car roads
that traverse the park so we
the first time that we sort of like
visualize this data you will see a ton
of traffic
a ton of people in the roads but these
were basically just cars like driving
and we didn't want to show this
so with the speed we were actually able
to filter anything that was moving like
faster than three miles per hour
so that way we were making sure that or
not making sure but trying to reduce the
chances that
the signals that we were capturing were
from uh moving the
vehicles into place
so once that you basically have the
hexes
uh the join is quite it's it's much
simpler right
because you sort of like reduce the
space where you have you need you need
to apply the
uh geographical functions
so in the example that i was given
before in my end that you have all this
point that has
that you have an index and then you join
to the
walton square so you first apply a first
pass where you
join that and then you can apply the geo
function to make sure
that your the points are actually inside
that
polygon the other thing that we did
is basically we parallelized the way
that we were
querying all the data so we split all
the data
so the data was coming to us already
partition by hour so it was quite easy
just to parallelize the process so every
hour
was running independent to each other
and that way the final result
we was almost an aggregation at the hour
level
and at the business level and for
everything that we did we basically use
airflow and
this was my first time using airflow
because in my
a drip advisor i we actually use
something that we building in-house
that allows you to do pretty much the
same but the way that you interact with
that is a little bit different but sort
of like the
concept of how to build pipelines are
the same you know you have dependencies
this can only run whenever this is done
there are parallel parallel tasks and
this is only one of the six different um
[Music]
etls that we have running for this
project uh
which is one of the more com more
complex and we're using
airflow with boto trees so that way we
can interact with all the
amazon services that we use and
and that way we can actually come up
with the final representation
of all the data before we actually send
it to mattbox which is one of the other
partners that actually
is able to render the map on the on the
site
finally like some of the technologies
that we use uh
so we have some a few ec2 instances so
each one of these is actually running
our flow so we have backup
of the data sorry of the process
we're using aspar emr something that i
didn't mention
uh about why history is very important
in the the way that it works is that
it's basically
it's a mapping operation so it's
basically you can take every single
record and it's gonna give you an index
and what this allows you is that it's
easy to distribute right so if you have
like
uh trying to like simplify what i'm
saying but if you have like
three different computers and you send
like three different files to each one
of those computers
they don't need to know what other
computer is doing or for you to get a
result of the data
so all it needs is basically a latitude
and longitude and the resolution
that you need and you will get the index
and then you can basically
reduce that data in any other way that
you need we're using s3 for storing the
data
and also for receiving the data so the
partners that provide data to us
they drop all the data in the pockets
and then we can use it
we're using dynamodb and this is um this
is directly from the
um our dynamodb is called directly by
the landa function on the site
and that returns some of the information
that you see on the side like
how like hours of operation and
all these different stuff we're using
ec2 for mapping between different
providers so
as i explained before to the two
partners that give us a telemetry data
is a
beta set and expo and they were both
really
um nice to work with but they are
actually competitors so
something that we wanted to make sure
that we didn't do is that we didn't mix
any of the data and trying to make sure
like we were not exposing any data that
can be used by
any of the companies so all the data
that we receive we basically map into
our own ids
so that way all the data is sort of like
internal
and nobody else can try to use this data
to map to something else
for the actual service that is rendering
the data we're using macbooks
and and to be honest i didn't work a lot
on the mac on the macbook side
the only thing that i did is that they
provide an api it's a python api
and it's quite easy to use like you need
just to define few things and then you
can basically just send the data to them
and like um through this
cli you can actually just ask to publish
the data and it's working
and finally amazon blender is basically
just the end point between the site
and the our backend
so i i mentioned before like so this
project that we
did is um basically we are not
i mean we're not monetizing this at all
and in fact everybody that works on this
i'm gonna happen it's like here for
everybody that worked on on this project
uh
everybody that worked on this was
basically volunteering their time
and sort of like was the agreement that
we trip advisor was not gonna try to
monetize this
and all the sponsors also provided all
either the data or the service or the
computing power
for free with the condition also that we
were not gonna monetize
the site um and yeah and
we were able to do it with the
collaboration of all of these companies
as well that's pretty much
all if you guys have any questions i'm
happy to take them
you do have a question from the chat
yeah
uh what's the smallest text you can you
can get from lane sadler
what's the smallest what
hex the smallest text that you can get
i think this is 19
it's uh i actually dropped the link in
the chat it's about 18 inches on each
side
okay so i i wasn't referring to the
actual like uh measure
but i think uh yeah i think there is uh
i remember saying this before 18 inches
well that's really small
um
oh it got it so in rest in extreme
resolution you go
up to 15 and this tells you actually how
many unique indexes are in the entire
world when you use this
so it's uh it's quite a lot for the
project we're actually using only
uh nine uh for businesses and 12
for uh open spaces because we want
smaller spaces so people can actually
see
something that looks quite nice for the
hitman
but yeah i i honestly was really blown
away by
this project anybody using geodata
i will encourage you to to look into h3
because it's quite powerful
and it has a really easy to use python
api
i mean i never really work with geodata
before and i was able to work with this
crazy
and and sort of like installing it into
all your workers when you're using
spark is also pretty easy um
so i will you can actually use it
oh excellent have you answered the
questions from sandeep
and we've got another from from pet pal
the uh
sandeep says did you have to deal for
all gps data from cell phone providers
uh i want to make sure this isn't the
question if so how
did you deal with the noisy data
especially in dense urban areas
oh yeah well that's well dense
urban urban areas is super challenging
um
because so so there are multiple things
one is a
gpa gps accuracy so
one of the values that we had from the
from the from the data set was how
accurate the signal was
so we actually do some like an algorithm
to try to see depending on what it is if
the radius
um if the accuracy is
bigger than the contour of the business
we basically wouldn't use it
for most of them it's around five meters
i believe
so it's usually pretty accurate but we
try to remove that kind of noise when
the
data is not that accurate and the second
thing that
we didn't solve for is actual building
so
if you go to new york you probably see a
building like it's a residential
building
and on the third floor they actually
have a business like you know like a
grocery store or something like that
so um in one of them we actually have
the
altitude like of the of the signal
but it's super super inaccurate so we
were not able to use that data to
remove it from our data set
uh all right the uh next and it looks
like for the moment last question is
from uh
i'm sorry for the name butchering but
pale is
i might have missed this but how do you
decide in the best
slash optimal hex size to do your
density analysis
was it gauging by visuals or another
method
sorry can you repeat again the question
i might have missed this but how do you
decide on the best
flash optimal hex size to your density
analysis
so yeah so
the answer to that is that so um
i mentioned here that we had a bunch of
volunteers um
on so we have some researchers
that perhaps then they did a really good
job and we have some people
on design and what they did
was basically they we basically took
only one day of data and we process all
this data
with different resolutions and they
actually created
uh like a study with different people
inside
tripadvisor because at that point we
couldn't share anything with people
where they were asking like what
resolution was it
easier to use to actually detect like
when something was more crowded or not
and this was uh the sort of like user
resolution
and 9 for data processing and 13 i'm
sorry and 12 for
heat maps was actually what looked the
best
we did some um testing with 13
but if you go in here like 13
it actually go from
1.6 like well it's sort of like go
like it's one like scale
higher on the on the on the number of
hexes that we'll get
we will get and and the sort of like the
value that we were getting from using
like
even like bigger resolution on the heat
maps was not
as um was not worth the cost so
once that you go into this you start
getting so much
like data on those cross joint that i
mentioned that it was
like really really i mean the entire
process was taking much longer
and we were also spending a lot of the
credit that aws were giving us to
for this project
uh all right if that's it caesar uh
looks like the final question well uh
do you have anything else to add to that
no i just want to say like
if like if any of this seems really
interesting and you want to go a little
bit deeper just let me know i'm happy to
you know like help anybody a little bit
with what i did
i'm not an expert on geo data but i
spent a lot of hours like working on
this project so
i'm super hap i'm super glad to share
sort of the knowledge that i
that i got um and and yeah don't
don't hesitate to reach out wait can i
ask a question sorry i
i was slow to the to the uptick here but
um
just uh about you're working with
openstreetmaster so i've worked with
that a little bit like how do you
like were there any like sort of lessons
learned with like working with that
because i know sometimes it's sparse and
sometimes like like iffy i don't know if
you like
have any tips for working with that data
so
they so
i guess they the part with open street
maps that was the most challenging
is that sometimes it contains polio that
are you
too big for us so for instance like the
white mountains in new hampshire
right so that's just massive
and we had to make like filters by area
some of these polygons
and the other part that i actually
didn't work on
was actually extracting all the data
from open stream maps
and i have a full presentation from the
person that actually did it
about how to do it and i'm happy to
share that as well
um well it's not like a super detailed
presentation but it gave you some idea
about the step that he followed in order
to extract all the data from
openstreetmaps
all right looks like we don't have any
more questions uh
if everyone's ready i guess it's time to
move on down the slides
to andrew's talk
all right great thanks um
let me share my screen one second all
right
does that look okay for everybody yes
andrew it looks perfect
great um well get started so thanks
everybody uh really happy to be back and
presenting in
in pi data boston again i'm gonna be
talking about a project that i worked on
last fall um i was doing it for
bloomberg news as a consultant
um before we get started just uh since i
know the question would come up
unfortunately i can't share the code to
what i did here since this was a
proprietary consulting project but i'm
happy to kind of talk through everything
i did and answer any questions i can
um you know i can share quite a bit just
can't show the code directly
so just to give a little bit of an
introduction um
my name is andrew terrio i am a
political scientist by training i did my
phd at nyu
i've been working in data science for
the past decade or so
i recently founded a company called
civin which focuses on the intersection
between
innovative tech companies and
governments and other public sector
organizations who need their help
in the past i've led data science and
analytics teams at places like the
democratic national committee
the city of boston and facebook i've
taught at harvard northeastern and i'm
actually one of the co-organizers of the
pi data boston chapter
so you know as i mentioned i'm talking
about a project i did last fall for
bloomberg news
and this was in the run-up to the 2020
election
i built a series of machine learning
models to predict voter turnout
for them to use in their election
coverage and i'll explain the motivation
in a minute
um as we go we'll walk through the
project and talk about
you know what the different challenges
were and and what i was thinking along
the way
so just to give a brief outline i'm
going to start by talking about the
specific
problem this project was designed to
solve and then from there i'm going to
go into the general
design of what my solution was we'll
talk for a while about the
implementation and some of the
challenges that came up
through that and then finally we'll talk
about how it actually went and
what we can learn from the process
so first off the problem of predicting
voter turnout in a pandemic
i think i'll start by talking about what
normally happens on election night
um and pardon the interruption if you
see your hearing corgi
who is uh thinking why am i on a call
during her playtime
um but we'll try to power through here
uh so on election night
generally what happens is that local
election officials
tally votes at the precinct level and
report their results
up to the counties and states and then
these results go
to the associated press or another
organization
and they publish these combined tallies
that's where you you know if you go to
the new york times or washington post or
wherever
to see election results coming in
they're all sharing some of these same
sources
and the key metric for tracking how much
of the vote has been counted
is what's called precincts reported um
basically what will happen is that
you know of all these individual
election precincts
that report results um you know we know
the total number of precincts there are
and we know how many of them have called
in their results
so we can basically just use that
proportion as a proxy for what
percentage of the vote has been counted
and you know this is an approximation
it's not perfect
um for one these precincts aren't all
the same size so
you know one percent of precincts it
doesn't actually mean one percent of
votes but it's close enough
it's a good enough approximation
likewise early and absentee votes
they're often counted and reported
differently from election day results
different cities and counties and states
handle these things and others
differently
um some might for example count your
absentee votes at your local precinct
others might count them at some central
county election office
um and you know what's more too is the
order in which these are reported
is is not random so for example places
with higher turnout
um oftentimes in urban areas they'll
tend to report later
whereas the places with relatively few
voters can do their accounts pretty
quickly
all that said though in a normal
election year the percent of precincts
reporting
tends to be a pretty good approximation
of how much of the vote's been counted
so this is what it looks like in
practice and as a former dnc official
we're sort of revisiting some of my 2016
trauma here
um but bear with me this is from the new
york times
website um from their election coverage
in 2016.
and so you can see here you know i
pulled up the denver
results specifically um it shows 346 out
of 346 precincts reporting
across the state uh it says 100
reporting
that's simply based on that precincts
reported number this is what it looks
like in a normal year
and that gives you a good sense of how
many votes are actually in compared to
how many there are going to be
so the problem with 2020 um the biggest
one
that came up well obviously there were a
lot of problems with 2020 but
the biggest one that came up in terms of
vote counting is that
almost two-thirds of the votes were
actually cast before election day
uh the previous high was about a third
in the last presidential election
and more than a third of the total votes
were cast by mail
and so part of the problem here is that
you know i mentioned a few minutes ago
that
those votes often aren't counted at the
same time has
um the in-person votes on election day
and sometimes not in the same places not
at the precinct level um what also often
happens
is that these are processed afterwards
um in some states for example
um this came up in pennsylvania early
votes aren't allowed to be counted
until the polls are already closed so
what might happen is that
you know you would get say voting
machines results almost instantaneously
after the polling
closes but you actually would have to
open all of these envelopes
uh and then process the paper apps and t
ballots one at a time
so those can take a lot longer we saw
you know during
well not election night election week
this uh last year
that pennsylvania actually took all the
way to you know the weekend in order to
be able to get all of those votes
counted
um also you know one of the problems
that we ran into was that the votes
didn't even have to be
in to the the state or county
by election day in many places that in a
lot of cases when the rules were relaxed
to allow easier vote by mail one of the
things that often got moved was the
requirement that votes
arrive by election day in a lot of
places what happened instead was
the votes had to be postmarked by
election day so that meant votes might
come in even
you know four five six days later um
i think some of them as much as a week
or two if they could come in
and so when two-thirds of the votes
aren't being cast
in the normal way on election day at
polling places suddenly that precincts
reporting estimate
isn't really a reliable indicator of how
much has been counted
so i got a call from bloomberg news to
help them
try to fix this problem for their
election night coverage
so the associated press had you know
told its members that
they were going to be putting out these
overall turnout predictions
for every state um but they hadn't said
you know how these are going to be done
and they weren't making any promises
about doing it at the county level
or for congressional districts or for
any race other than the presidential
election
so that's what bloomberg news reached
out to me for um
you know they knew me from from
reputation from my past work with the
dnc and elsewhere
and so you know i agreed with them to
put together
uh predictions for each state for each
county for each
congressional district in the case of
congressional races and for presidential
senate house and gubernatorial races so
these would what these would be what
bloomberg news used on election night
in their coverage instead of the
precincts reporting measure
so to do this i designed a voter turnout
forecast model
and before we get to the details of the
model i think it's worth pointing out
that making a model like this
has some fundamental problems that you
need to wrestle with
the biggest one more than anything else
is that an election is a one-time event
that you know yes we have presidential
elections every four years
but they're not the same thing there are
different candidates different contexts
this year there was last year there's a
pandemic you know
these kinds of things happen and so um
what often
happens here is that you know we try to
proxy
by looking at previous selections as
a a a baseline but it's not the same
thing so
particularly in a year where it's just a
fundamentally different environment than
any that's come before
it gets really hard to come up with
accurate prediction
and what's more contrary to what 538
the economist and other you know
predictions might tell you
you can't actually quantify the
uncertainty of a one-time event
this is a sort of a philosophical
question but it's it's impossible
because
you know you can't if something happens
right
if an event happens all you know about
the probability of that event happening
is that it wasn't zero that's all you
can say
um you can't say whether the probability
of that event happening was a hundred
percent
or point zero zero zero one percent we
just happened to get to that one
um it's really impossible to say when
you only have one observation
so you can try to estimate it from other
similar events but that's not the same
thing
and likewise um the other problem that
you run into by using those past events
that are similar
is that you're relying on having
comparable data and that the data
generating mechanisms
that produce that are are comparable so
for example um just as a starting point
yes we've had you know over 50
presidential elections in this country
but
we don't have all the same data going
back that far
um in fact you know just getting county
level presidential election
returns um you can only do that for the
past 20 years
and and other data sources for example
the american community survey
basically what the census bureau
produces um
in years that aren't divisible by 10 to
say how many people there are and what
their demographics are and so forth
you know that doesn't go back to 2000
its current format you know it's i mean
it's change it changes a little bit from
year to year but the current format of
the acs
really only goes back about a decade
likewise
um the district boundaries for
congressional districts even
the the counties in the country they do
change over time so again it's really
hard to get
comparable data that lines up um and
then when you're talking about rules
things like uh you know who's eligible
to vote absentee
how much early voting there is um
certain states now
do all vote by mail where you know
that's a
rapidly growing thing but that wasn't
the case 20 years ago
um so you have to account for all of
these things and it's really hard to get
all of the data line up
and then finally like i said 2020 was a
very unusual year for many reasons
and so you know expecting the uh the
patterns you saw
in previous elections to hold is a bit
of a challenge
so my goal here wasn't to come up with a
perfect solution it's one that
was good enough and and this is sort of
a philosophical approach i have about
these kinds of projects
then i'm not going for a perfect
solution i'm going for a solution
that's better than whatever it is we'd
have if i didn't
do the work so in this case you know
maybe that solution
is the aps forecast which doesn't get at
the level of granularity we want
or you know it's going to be something
that 538 produces or somebody else or
maybe they're just going to look at you
know the last election results and say
well it'll be something more than that
most likely
um in any case you know i thought well i
can't do better or i can't do a perfect
thing
but i can do better than those so it's
actually really freeing to think about
it that way to realize that
you know you're never gonna have a
perfect solution but you can always make
it better
and so that's my approach to essentially
start with some kind of baseline
um you know in this case i took simply
the the
turnout rates we saw in each county and
state
from previous elections and then you
know i thought what can i add to that to
make it
um more accurate over time so
one thing to remember here too is that
data is always going to be messy and
this very much was i'll get into that
uh in a minute um but perhaps most
importantly of any of these things i
think it's also really critical
to be honest with yourself and with
everybody else about
what you don't know or what you can't
know and and plan to work around that
so translating all these philosophical
approaches into
practical ideas for this project um
first off
you know i had to real really make some
trade-offs about the amount of data i
could use
versus how accurate that was so for
example um you know i ended up only
going back to 2004 with presidential
results
i could have actually gone back to the
1970s if i wanted to use state level
um but you know that only gives us about
50 data points a year rather than three
thousand like we did with counties
um and you know i wanted i had to leave
2000 out
only because basically we're using the
lagged um turnout rate from the previous
election
as one of the inputs so we didn't have
that for 96
which meant we couldn't use 2000 for
training
we also had to you know think about
where
is this data going to be accurate so for
example i mentioned the american
community survey a few minutes ago as
you know something that in its current
form only goes back about a decade
well i went back about two decades in
the election results and what that meant
was i had to do a combination of um
different kinds of adjustments really to
come up with estimates for you know the
2008
and 2004 numbers where essentially i'm
you know just did a really simple
trend model from the uh the data that i
had for 2012 and 2016 in 2020
um and those kind of things you know
come up along the way and you have to
make
some really tough decisions about when
to to make those compromises and when
not
uh as i went through the other thing i
needed to do was to
you know find a way to approximate
uncertainty even if you can't actually
quantify it
exactly for the reasons i mentioned in
the last slide
um you can at least try to approximate
it
by testing it out on other elections so
in this case
you know i actually made four sets of
validation models one holding out each
of the four
presidential years that i was modeling
and use that to get a rough sense of how
much uncertainty i should expect
but the biggest thing i did here
actually is to recognize that
you know the things that cause
variation in turnout rates across
counties or across states
those are things i can estimate
uncertainty
around using past years data fairly well
i can at least say
you know this is probably going to be
right plus or minus 5
80 or 90 of the time um what's much
harder is to say
hey here's how 2020 is going to be
different than 2016 or 2012 or 2008
and that overall level of turnout you
know we knew it was
very likely to be high but it was really
hard to say how high and so as i'll talk
about
a little further on we actually ended up
making three
different uh sets of forecasts based on
three different
turnout level scenarios and the idea was
that on election night we could actually
use the incoming data that we were
getting
from the states and counties to say at
what point should we switch from one
forecast to another
so the final design of the model that i
created um
the most important model was the model
of the county level presidential turnout
rates
so looking at at the number of votes as
a function
of the citizen voting age population and
so
the inputs to this i mentioned already
uh turn on previous
mid midterm and presidential elections i
also brought in a lot of information
about voting rules
um things like voter id and whether
felons are disenfranchised and so forth
there's a whole set of different
demographics that are relevant here and
you know a lot of this is based actually
in the work that i've done
back in my academic days you know
studying what are the things that
predict whether individual voters are
likely to turn out
and then i also brought in a lot of
information about the competitiveness
of the presidential race in each state
and about races for senate and governor
as well again
under you know the pretty well
established finding that the more
competitive
a specific race the more people are
likely to turn out
there's a second set of models as well
about what's called down ballot drop-off
this is when people show up they'll cast
a vote for president but they won't vote
for
senate or governor or house of
representatives
they'll only vote at the top of the
ticket and so i made a second set of
models
predicting this drop off as a function
of the competitiveness of those down
ballot rates
races a few voting rules and
socioeconomic status again things that
are established in the political science
research has pretty strong predictors of
behavior
so i mentioned earlier that i validated
these models by holding out
one year's elections at a time and then
finally what i did was i retrained the
models on all the all four elections
and predicted for the 2020 context and
then made the adjustments
to produce those high and historic level
forecasts
that i alluded to in the previous slide
and i'll get into a little more detail
about those as we go on
so now a bit about the implementation so
probably half the work on this project
was really just about finding and
compiling the right data
so you know one of the main data sources
that i started from
was election result data that was
compiled at mit
which has the most comprehensive and
granular
election result data
and you know in this data this was the
data set that
we get county data um for presidential
elections going back to 2000
um you could also get state data for
senate and gubernatorial races
uh congressional district level data for
congressional races
um you know what i found with this is
it's generally
very comprehensive very high quality
but that said you know there are issues
in there i found for example in some
cases um you know the definitions of
counties didn't line up because
certain results were reported um for
example in virginia where they often
would have
a sort of joint county where they have a
city
and the area around it um they're
technically different counties but they
report their
their election results together um those
kind of things came up i found a few
just
basic math errors that i don't know
where they came from but the numbers
were just
off um thankfully i did some validation
that helped me find
hopefully most of those but there were
some cases too where i had to dig into
places like ballotpedia and wikipedia
to try to pull out some more some other
sources of information
i mentioned the demographic data from
the american community survey
the census bureau also puts out the
current population survey which provides
some
similar data at different levels and
frequencies
i pulled competitiveness from a bunch of
different sources
the the more recent stuff um it's pretty
easy to get from places like 538 with
all their polling archives
um ballotpedia is really good at
compiling data
on uh race competitiveness rankings
from um you know a few different uh
sort of mainstream sources like the cook
political report
that's a pretty standard one that goes
back a while that said though
you know those data sources generally
start out
um around 2012 or so that's when those
those organizations started compiling
that prior to that i actually had to go
and do things like
look up old um newspaper articles
from say you know 2000 or 2004 or
whatever
um to try to find you know what for
example the cook ratings were
back in 2004 um because they're not
available online anywhere
you know those sorts of things i had to
go back and and dig around to find
likewise i also had to go to a lot of
different sources to get information
about voting rules
again this is one of those things where
it's not too hard to get current data
but when you start trying to roll back
in time that's where it gets tough i had
to go and research and say you know for
example
um when did a certain state start
requiring voter id
so that i can code you know the
elections before then as not requiring
it
but the elections afterwards is
requiring it um because that's one of
the things that we're thinking about in
terms of what predicts
overall turnout rates it's not only you
know what the rules are now but what
they were
at the time of a previous election and
even how they had changed in the run-up
to that election
so all that's to say getting data that's
consistent across years
was a real struggle and you know one of
the things that i i wrestled with
is the subjectivity in deciding when
data is good enough and when it's not
um you know i feel like if you had a
hundred people do this project
you would have a hundred very different
projects because i think everybody
will have different views about you know
how to make these trade-offs
and there's no one right or wrong answer
there's no standard for how to do this
um ultimately this is the sort of art of
the art and science of this kind of
project
so i did most of this work in jupiter um
i think a lot of you are familiar with
jupiter notebooks
and if you're really a big fan
of jupiter workflows i did a jupiter con
presentation a few years back on
um using jupiter notebooks and
production and
kind of how i approach that but just to
really kind of summarize how i do a lot
of projects
normally um the way i start and i'm
speaking as really a data scientist
not an engineer so um you know i'm sure
a lot of software engineers would
would cringe at what i do um at the
other end of the spectrum i think a lot
of you know researcher types
wouldn't get past the v 0.1 so i'm okay
with being in the middle there
um but so what i started doing is doing
everything in linear code
you know i do things one at a time in
either one or many notebooks
and then the next step what i'll do is
i'll take things that generalize
particularly around things like building
models i'll move them
into functions within the notebook and
i'll start pulling out the parameters
put them say up at a block at the top of
the notebook so i can
play around with them as needed without
having to dig through all the code
the v 0.3 is often moving those
functions into modules and importing
them
basically that's what i do once i get
those functions in a place where i'm
happy with them and don't need to make
changes
the optional v04 is maybe i just move
everything into a standard python script
i mentioned that jupiter con
presentation a minute ago i find this
part to be more and more optional over
time because you can actually use
notebooks in a production setting if
you're not familiar with something
called nb convert
i i would advise you to look into it um
if you're interested because
what it allows you to do is to schedule
a notebook run where
you don't actually have to be doing it
manually it can run on a
cron job or an airflow or whatever and
you can get all the
same outputs you would as if you had it
open in the browser and then finally i
move everything to production
but so for this one uh this was a sort
of
fast-paced project you know i had about
six weeks to put it together
i was also working alone and this was
something that you know hopefully i
wouldn't have to do again anytime soon
so i went with the sort of hybrid hybrid
approach um hybrid of
0.1 for the brand new code and 0.3 for
things i've adapted from
other projects um you know like a lot of
you i'm sure
over time i've realized i do a lot of
the same things the same way
particularly when it comes to machine
learning um so i got a pretty well built
out code base of
you know how i do things like model
tuning that i can just reuse for
different projects
um you know it wasn't the cleanest most
elegant approach like i said a lot of
software engineers might object
um it worked great for me and especially
to uh
needing to move quickly i felt like that
strike the right balance that said
um you know this is one that i was
working alone on
and it wasn't something that i was going
to need to replicate later so
if those are considerations you know
maybe try to be a little more deliberate
in your workflow
so one thing i did a lot of in this was
ensembling
so this is a common thing too when i'm
making models
for those of you who aren't familiar
with ensembling generally the basic
thinking is that you know every model
has weaknesses
um but by combining different algorithms
the idea is hopefully
by averaging those predictions together
you can cancel out some of the
weaknesses and build a model
that's better than what you can get from
any individual algorithm
so the final presidential turnout models
we used
um they used three different tree based
algorithms random forests extra trees
and gradient boosted decision trees
and the idea behind this was just that
each of these algorithms handles the
input features in a slightly different
way
um for example you know random forest
regressions
they tend to give more weight than extra
trees regressions do
to um continuous features because of the
way they select where to split
um make splits within your data set
um i could talk for hours about the the
logistics of that just suffice it to say
that you know they tend to focus a
little more on continuous
variables whereas extra trees models
tend to go a little more towards the
binary variables and so
the idea of combining them together is
that you know you give different
features a chance to shine in each in
each model
so that you know none of them just
happens to not really get much attention
simply because
the particular algorithm you used just
really doesn't have much of a taste for
that kind of feature
um i also tried using linear regression
and various kinds of regularization
but i found actually in the testing they
made the ensemble predictions worse
um tree models tend to be really
flexible um
you know regression based or linear
regression based models
aren't very flexible um and so
you know you either have to build in a
lot of interactions manually
or else you just have to accept that um
you know
interactions between the different
inputs aren't going to be accounted for
and so that made the predictions
substantially worse i ended up excluding
them at the end
the one exception was for the down
ballot models
in those cases we had a much smaller
sample um
you know for the senate and governor
races we were doing it at the state
level
so only a couple hundred data points
and i apologize if you hear my dog
squeaking her toy she does this when i'm
on zoom sometimes
um so you know we had a few we had a lot
fewer data samples
um we had fewer features and simpler
specifications
so for those i just use linear
regression for simplicity
but for the much larger presidential
turnout models that's where we actually
use
all of the tree based models so
there's a lot of tuning that went on in
this um
you know i spent a lot of time manually
collecting and refining the data but
what that actually translated to in the
modeling
wasn't so much setting up the model that
took time as figuring out
you know which which algorithms to use
how to choose the right set of features
to include
there's a lot of tuning and retraining
also when i went back and i would pull
in
you know a slightly improved set of data
after i did some
some error checking and so forth and the
basic setup here of
you know what went into this just the
presidential models we had about three
thousand a little over three thousand
counties
four years of data um depending on the
run anywhere from 50 to 100 features
three to five algorithms at a time we
were tuning
three to five hyper parameters per
algorithm
we were doing four validations sets of
models plus
the final set of models all that those
numbers don't really mean much
other than say there was a lot of
horsepower that we had to use to
to compute this and the laptop i got a
few years ago
um it was meant so i could put in a bag
back when we used to leave the house and
go work in other places
which is and it's great for that it's
not that powerful though and so
the solution i found um was actually to
use a tool called desk
so if you're not familiar with das dasc
is a python library
that basically allows you to distribute
data tasks
across different workers and in
particular where it shines is
doing it when you're distributing across
a cluster um
on more than one machine you could also
use it for parallelizing things on a
single machine
it's a good use case for that but in
this case you know deploying on a
cluster was really what i was going for
and i used a product called coiled
coiled
is a company that was started by the
creators of das they have a product
called coil cloud which is essentially
a um das cluster as a service
on aws so desk when you're using it for
this use case
it's basically a drop-in replacement for
job lib inside kit learn
job lib allows you to parallelize a job
like in this case
a randomized cert parameter search
job lib lets you do that on one machine
desk lets you do it either on one
machine or on a cluster
and so switching to the desk back end
was actually really simple it was
less than 10 lines of code took me under
an hour um
the exception of a little debugging i
had to do um
just basically because the first time
i'd done it and i actually work on
windows unlike most people and so
um there are a few nuances about it but
it was pretty quick to do and um
i've since used it on other projects and
it's literally no more work than using
scikit-learn on its own
um and the beautiful thing here is that
coil because it's still in beta
is actually free at this point it still
is there's a link here um
if this is your thing i definitely
recommend trying it um i was really
happy with how it turned out
uh because i was able to use up to 200
cores
on their cluster and so i set up a
cluster of 48
machines each of which was as powerful
or more powerful than my laptop
so you can imagine what that did to the
time it took to run everything
so this is just a screenshot i grabbed
at the time this is their monitoring
system
um in this case this was around one
round of hyper parameter tuning
for uh it looks like an extra trees
model
um what it's showing here is all
i think 48 jobs running the whole thing
to do this
uh took about like two and a half
minutes it looks like um that's the kind
of thing that before i switched over
was about an hour or two to run locally
and so that really sped up the iteration
time
so then what i did is is i mentioned
validating the models where i held out
one year each
and so there were two purposes for this
one was just to make sure that the
models actually worked as intended and
that you know
i was able to produce useful forecasts
um but more importantly i also wanted to
get a good sense of what the uncertainty
in the predictions is was likely to be
when i made a model of
of other years than the one i was
testing it
um so basically this allowed us to look
both
you know how much variance do we expect
to see in our predictions
across counties or across states but
also overall um
because that's the really hard thing and
the hard thing that i was
worried a lot about when it came to
2020. um
how do those year by year patterns
change so
on that last point looking at the four
different years
um basically it ranged from our
predictions being about
three and a half percent too low um
in 2004 to 16.3 percent too high in
2012.
um which kind of makes sense you know
for example the 2012 one in particular
um 2008 was a really um high turnout
year
compared to some of the previous ones in
2012
we did see turnout drop pretty
substantially
from from 2008. so remember i mentioned
that
you know the past elections turnout um
was one of the big inputs well it makes
sense then that
you know if that's our starting point um
and turnout goes down pretty
substantially that we are going to see
um you know our forecast coming in a bit
high
so then going down to look at the more
granular level um
this is where i really want to just get
a sense of like how close
were we overall so there are always
going to be outliers when you do these
things
um and i looked a lot at the outliers to
see you know where their
particular patterns um that were coming
up you know places
for example one of the things that i did
as a result of
um doing some of that outlier checking
was to actually
incorporate as a feature um the growth
rate of the population in a certain area
because what i was finding was that
there were some places that were rapidly
growing or shrinking
where it seemed the um the census
estimates actually weren't keeping up
with the changing population in part
because we only had census data from
two years prior because for 2020 the
last estimates we had were 2018.
so we had to do the same thing in
previous years to use the lag data
um but also you know this was something
i did to find
um some some errors in the data look and
see where our forecasts were way off
and you know in a number of cases um you
know we're able to find oh that result
is just
fundamentally wrong so it was really
useful for that purpose but
you know mostly i want to say well we
know how liars are going to happen
what i want to make sure is we get it
within a reasonable range most of the
time
so i looked at the the 10th and 90th
percentiles
and you know going in both directions
we were within about six percentage
points um
you know either five five point three
percent too low at the tenth percentile
or six percent too high at the 90th and
for the median county
we were plus or minus about three
percent of
uh what the actual result was so overall
you know my takeaway here was this is
pretty good
um you know we're not dead on and and i
never expected to be
like i said my goal was a good enough
solution
but i thought this was pretty solid and
this is something that
you know i figured is going to provide a
pretty useful forecast
so just to illustrate what this looked
like so
you know i i did the the numeric
summarization on the previous page
these are some of the graphs i produced
um this is
for validations for 2004 and 2008 those
being the holdout years
um you know you can see on the
horizontal axis
the the predicted turnout rate and then
on the vertical axis
the actual turnout rate and the dots
here are scaled by the size of the
county
um you know you can see that
particularly um
when you see the the extreme outliers
you know a lot of them tend to be the
really small dots
um because they're just a lot more
variants around smaller places
um but you see in both cases we actually
track really well
um you know if you're looking at the r
squared of this i don't
have the exact numbers in front of me
but you know you can guess it's it's
quite high
and so this is really reassuring to say
yes you know
the approach we're using here um you
know there's some variants in terms of
or i should say there's some bias in
terms of
you know you can see for example in um i
mentioned before that in 2004
we're about three percent um too low on
average and you can see that because
you know the um
you know the the typical results most of
them are
sort of above and to the left of the
diagonal line
um that means we're predicting too low
2008 though we're about dead on
there's very little bias in that year um
so that was
pretty reassuring and that also gave us
a good sense of you know
approximately what uncertainty we should
expect
so getting ready to actually go live on
election day um
one of the things we decided to do was
rather than present a single estimate
of how many votes we expect instead we
presented our forecast
as a range um and we decided to go with
plus or minus five percent
you know i mentioned before that um the
10th and 90th percentiles we were seeing
by county were you know between
negative five and positive six um you
know i said about plus minus five
percent that i figure
figuring that should capture you know
definitely the majority of cases
um hopefully at least about two thirds
maybe three quarters
you know and that seemed like a pretty
reasonable target the end of the day
though this is kind of arbitrary the
goal here wasn't
that this is any precise estimate of
what we expect to see and we didn't
present it that way you know we
we basically just said look we expect in
most cases
the result will fall within that range
and and
to you know give a bit of a spoiler they
did it worked out
um one important thing we did here was
actually applied the same range
at all levels so this is something that
um
really gets to the structure of errors
and
for me this is um particularly important
because when you see
something like a polling forecast um
what oftentimes pulling forecasts rely
on and this was one of the big problems
in 2016
why so many forecasts got it wrong is
they assume that
you know by averaging different polls
together um
the errors will kind of cancel each
other out and you won't have what are
called correlated errors which is that
you know all the polls may be wrong in
the same direction
um by applying the same range at the
county level the state level and the
national level
what we said was basically that you know
we're saying
the same uncertainty level at all levels
meaning that um
we might be you know wrong in the same
direction every time
and that's okay we'll still you know
we're not going to assume these things
are just going to cancel out
but the other thing we did too is i
mentioned before that we calculated
three different
types of forecasts based on three
different levels of turnout
so our baseline forecast was just on our
model's predictions
so what that said was let's take you
know the average of the trends we saw
across
across the past four elections not just
average the turnout levels but the sort
of turnout patterns generally
and adjust them by changes in for
example the rules around voting so
you know when there's more absentee and
early voting
that tends to increase um turnout rates
so we did allow for that and so you know
we were looking at
a an increase in the turnout rate over
the average of the past four
um four cycles but you know fairly
modest one
but you know that said we were looking
at the number i believe it was something
like 142 million
um our baseline turnout forecast and you
know this was lower
than well pretty much everybody else's
forecasts
um it's also just lower than we we
realistically expected
um you know there are a lot of different
signs of enthusiasm we were seeing among
the electorate
that we couldn't ultimately incorporate
um
you know one of the things that often
comes up is in surveys
you know people ask about how excited
people are to vote
generally the question about asking
people do they plan to vote it's
actually not a great question
but other measures of enthusiasm can be
fairly predictive
at least from to tell one election from
the next
um but again this is one of those
problems where we didn't have consistent
data
going back to all the previous elections
so we couldn't account for that so
you know this was a case where we were
seeing things in the data but we
couldn't put in the model because
we didn't have data from previous years
that was comparable um
just for comparison like the 538
forecast
they had their sort of magic formula
of how they generated term turnout
forecasts and they simply said hey we
think
you know enthusiasm is i don't know 20
i'm just making this up but you know 20
higher than it was last time
and so we're going to make an adjustment
but you know
as far as i could tell totally arbitrary
what that was set at and so
i didn't want to do something like that
instead what we did was say
well you know we we don't know how
uh how high turnout is going to be but
you know we think
that the baseline model the the model
from our turnout
uh forecast based on previous years
let's say that's the low end so high
turnout we said is going to be about
five percent higher and
you know that five percent figure um you
know we basically just looked at the
variance across previous elections so
um five percent is basically about the
same as the difference in turnout
rates between 2004 and 2008 those
examples i showed you earlier
um and you know generally 2008 was a
pretty high fork
or a high turnout election going back
you know the past
several decades so we said okay you know
the difference between a
a very a high turnout election and a
normal one it's roughly five percent
again this is kind of arbitrary because
at the end of the day we don't
this isn't something where we can we can
estimate precisely so we're not even
going to try
instead we said you know looking at the
data that seems like the difference
based on historical patterns of between
a normal election and a high turnout one
but then looking at at this year or at
2020
there were a lot of signs that it was
actually going to be more than that um
you know in particular looking at the
rate of early and absentee voting
um i showed earlier that you know we had
over 100 million votes cast before
election day
um and that's more than double we'd ever
seen in the past
um and obviously a lot of those voters
were people who otherwise would have
turned out on election day
but still um you know that was a really
strong sign the enthusiasm was very high
likewise all the other signs you know
pointed the same direction
so we also decided to come up with this
historic forecast which simply takes
the high turnout forecast adds another
five percent to it
um and decided essentially that we're
going to
you know start with the baseline
forecast and then move from one to the
next to the next throughout election
night
based on the data that comes in and
finally um the other thing we did before
we
released was we wrote up a pretty
extensive methodology document
and published it for everybody to see so
you know one of the things we were
trying to do here was to be really
transparent about what we were doing
what the inputs were um give some sense
of what the uncertainty all meant
you know this was a pretty complex
project and i wanted to make sure that
um well i wasn't going to get to the
level of you know
making it totally academic um i wanted
to make it so that a you know
sophisticated reader would get a good
sense of
what they were looking at
so finally the last section before we
wrap up
what happened so on election night
the plan was you know we're going to
load up our baseline forecast
and for each as i said before for each
state and county
we'll be showing a range of the total
votes we expect
and so the plan was that you know we
have these high
and historic turnout forecasts and what
we did is we set some
conditions for when we're going to
switch from one to the other and that's
based on
you know certain number of counties or a
certain number of states
crossing um the upper bound of the range
of whatever
turnout forecast we're using right now
um you know we presume we're only going
to go
up from uh the baseline um we did set
some conditions for when we might roll
back but
we didn't expect to have to use that and
then on the site itself what it would
show
is the counting progress for votes as a
percentage
of the expected number of votes under
the forecast that is it
ends up becoming a range of percentages
as i'll show in a minute
um and we also make a point of
explaining which forecast
we're using at any given time um that's
why you know if you looked at one point
in time and saw
oh we were you know somewhere between
say 80 and 80
and 90 percent of the votes counted and
then suddenly
you looked again and it said 75 to 85
the reason would
be if you looked at it that oh we've
switched from one forecast to another
so first off the national tracker this
is what was on the front page of the
site
you know it had um like you've seen a
lot of places you know it'll have all
the states
you can mouse over it and pull up the
state-specific info
they also had a tracker to look at the
um
the progress of counting votes overall
um and to look at the sort of partisan
composition
within each of those um they also did
some cool things around
you know those lines on the right um the
reason the colors change
over the course of it is so they can
kind of track the progress
of um votes that come in so for example
if you look at say um nevada you know it
started out very red
um because clark county which is where
las vegas is the really blue part of the
state
that counted more slowly than the you
know more rural parts and so
the votes that came in late were much
more democratic
than the early ones anyways you can kind
of get a sense here too
these aren't the final results this
stopped updating before
every state had finalized its vote
counting um but this is close to it you
can kind of
get a sense just looking at this um how
close we were to the
100 of the forecast um and this is
i'll mention a minute i'll get into this
in a minute this is the historic turnout
forecast
which we we got to uh very late on
election night
um but you'll see you know for on
average we were
just about in the right territory there
were some places that were a little high
or a little low
um overall it worked out pretty well and
when you looked at
individual states here's georgia for
example um the way you would see it
is you know they would show the results
and the number of votes counted
but then again show you know how many
votes have count
have been counted and then what the
range of expected votes here
is so in this case georgia there were 5
million votes in total
the range of this historic voter turnout
forecast
was 4.78 to 5.28 million
um which means you know the the the mean
of that is 5.03 so we were dead on
in in georgia um unfortunately we were
really close in a lot of places
particularly
places that turned out to be really
close
the problem with florida um i mean i
kind of laughed when i wrote this
because
i could come up with many issues to take
up with florida but
um in this case actually it's not
florida's fault they actually did
something right
um which was they reported their vote
counts super early
and it was really frustrating because
what was happening was
there was super high turnout in florida
and they actually were one of the
the states that really over performed
relative to our forecasts
um but you know by pretty early in the
evening you know around 9 00 p.m
most of the places were were fully
reporting um and at that point in the
night you know no other state
was anywhere close to as um you know as
as
complete as they were and they were
getting a lot of attention
um particularly because it came in much
more republican than expected
and so we were still on our baseline
forecast and we're seeing some counties
coming in as
120 of our forecast or more um
and so you know the the team that i was
working with at bloomberg graphics
um they were getting calls from the news
desk saying hey why the hell is our our
forecast so far off
and then they were asking me and i said
well we have these rules and we're not
there yet
um and so we're really stressing out
about this um
we hadn't met the trigger for going to
high we did eventually
um just you know later that evening
switch it up there i don't know
i think we got close to the actual
trigger we might have even crossed it
but um
you know we at some point we just
realized yes it's obviously gonna get
there
um and you know in hindsight we'd
probably adjust the rules a little bit
but overall it worked it was a little
slower than expected um we also switched
to the historic forecast
around 5 a.m or so um i don't remember
exactly when it was some time before
dawn
because i started i remember going to
bed around the time the sun came up that
morning
um and then waking up a couple hours
later and getting back online but
um yeah you know we made that switch we
ended up getting to that historic
forecast
and ultimately i'm glad we did um just
to contrast
the florida example though um the
problem with new york
has their own folks say this is city and
state which is one of the new york
political
magazines um they described it as a
national embarrassment
because even weeks after the votes were
cast in new york they still hadn't
finished counting
um they even managed to miss legal
deadlines to do so
um and this is true for several states
so that's why uh you know when when you
look at the site as it is now
um it's actually showing that we only
got to about 96
of the forecast in in nationally um and
that's because
you know then when they stopped it about
a month after the election um not all
the votes were in in places like new
york were actually still reporting
so overall uh we're actually pretty much
right on target
so the final vote count was just a
little under 160 million
our forecast was 161. um the range was
you know 157 to 165 so
you know we were within basically a
percentage point um
of of the actual turnout number that's
our historic forecast you know
that's because we were able to adjust
with time
um but that was the point you know
worked as as expected
and what i think was really pleasing to
me was that in a lot of key swing states
um our forecast was similarly dead-on so
you know places like georgia michigan
nevada north carolina
we were within one percent um places a
couple places like pennsylvania
wisconsin we were a couple points off
but not far
um we did see some places where we're
off by quite a bit
um places like ohio and or sorry not
ohio hawaii and idaho
um but that said you know and this was
kind of my focus i
didn't do anything with waiting to do
this but i definitely um made a point of
you know really focusing on the the data
checking on
um places that i expected to be swing
states um you know if i saw
a potential data issue in idaho i wasn't
going to waste a lot of time trying to
fix it
but if it was wisconsin i absolutely was
um
but likewise you know i think a lot of
this has to do with
uh turnout being more consistent in
places that are highly competitive
um so at the end of the day everything
was within plus or minus seven percent
of the historic forecast and and most
places were within
plus or minus five percent so you know
that's what we were hoping for and and
that's what we got
all right so finally um you know i was
really pleased with how this worked out
2020 was a hellish nightmare of a year
in a lot of ways um and i was very
pleasantly surprised to see that this
one thing actually went as well as i
could have expected
um but the real credit you know doesn't
go towards some
brilliant design um or magic it was
humility
the the humility of presenting forecasts
as ranges so you set
the expectation for the audience that
you're not going to be exactly right
every time
and this is one of the mistakes i think
that places like 538 have made
um you know in 2016 for example
you know they got a lot of heat as did
pretty much everybody else who was
aggregating polls
for you know missing the election
because they were off by a couple points
um you know that was partly
the fault of what i mentioned about um
those correlated errors
where you're getting a little too cocky
that everything's just gonna
you know even out when you aggregate all
this information together
and so in our case we presented these
ranges
to set the expectation clearly that yeah
we're probably going to be off by a few
points
here and there but that's okay that's
that's just the plan
um likewise we didn't assume that those
errors were going to average out
um we we presented you know as much
uncertainty at the national level as we
did for counties
and then we designed the system knowing
that it was impossible
to know everything in advance that 2020
was going to surprise us
and so rather than either pretend it
wasn't
or to throw up our hands what we said
was you know let's design a system
that allows us to adapt to the data
that's coming in
in a really basic way it wasn't
something like you know the new york
times needle or what washington post did
at the very end
where they tried to come up with some
dynamic forecasts
um remember the washington post they
didn't turn it on to like two days later
because it turns out you know those
models are really hard and i've done
that before
i did that at the dnc in 2014 i had no
uh no wish to ever do that again you
know so we did something really simple
which is
let's come up with a low medium and high
forecast and switch from one
to the other based on the totality of
the results that are coming in
and so that actually ended up being a
very simple
um but very effective solution to get
to you know the answer we needed which
was how many votes are going to be cast
um the end of the day we got there and
we answered the question we needed to
that said definitely room for
improvement um one thing
i would do differently is pay more
attention up front to data quality
and part of that might mean scaling back
my ambitions about what data i was going
to include
i think particularly a lot of the things
about voting roles
you know i i kind of felt like well we
need all the information about voter id
and felon disenfranchisement and
how many days of early voting there are
in every state in every election
and you know ultimately when i actually
ended up running the models
um most of those didn't prove that
valuable anyways
but it was a hell of a lot of work and
it could have introduced as much noise
as it took away i don't know
um but i think for the sake of doing
this more efficiently in the future i
think
you know paying attention to the data
that we know is quality would probably
be a better approach
um in terms of the adaptive forecast um
i mentioned
the the problem with florida and moving
from different level one level of
turnout to another
i think in the future i'd be a bit more
uh willing to take risks on that
um the problem we ran into with florida
was we didn't we didn't have a mechanism
to just say
hey there's one place that we think is a
good indicator of where everything's
going
so we're going to move the national
forecast based on that
um you know and in hindsight if i were
doing again i'd either
make the rules a lot more loose as to
when we do that or maybe
you know do it on say a state by state
basis so we could have
say flip florida to the historic
forecast
um early on in the night rather than
have to wait and kind of look silly for
a little while
um and then finally the other thing i do
was when i was going through this and
thinking about
you know sort of my philosophy
approaching these projects i realized i
did one thing that really goes against
the way that i like to do it and the way
i actually teach my students how to do
it
um because one thing i always like to
remind my students is that
you can always add complexity later it's
much harder to take it away and i think
i violated that
when i did this project i came up with
this really long list
of all the things i thought it should be
included um and i kind of started from
there and i took a few
out along the way once i realized say
that i couldn't get
some data set that i needed um but in
hindsight
if i were to do it again i'd probably go
the other way and i would start building
up more gradually because it's really
unclear to me how much of that
complexity was really necessary
i mentioned things like voting rules
where at the end of the day the features
actually didn't add a whole lot of value
and i think that's probably the case for
a lot of things for example
you know i mean i was able to look and
see
hey for example um you know adding
adding
uh additional algorithms to the
ensembles
you know yeah they improved overall
performance in terms of
my sort of key metrics but i didn't
really
dive in and see like is this a
meaningful difference and
is this slight you know improvement in r
squared or whatever metric i was using
um
you know is that really worth the added
complexity of having multiple algorithms
and having to retune everything
um you know you know i'd say maybe i'd
go back and try it a little more simply
see how well that performs and then only
add complexity
if it actually makes the model um
notably better in a really substantial
way
so that's all i've got um i've got a few
time a few minutes if anybody has any
questions i think i saw some pop up in
the chat
um you can always find me on twitter i'm
i'm very easy to find there
and and you'll find lots of uh corgi
photos
and burritos as well as snarky comments
about tech
you can also shoot me an email here and
i've posted the slides on my github
i did that right before this um so if
you want a copy just go there and grab
them
um you know and feel free to share or
send me an email if you have any
questions
with that um yeah i'll take a few
questions from the chat
uh all right there are a few uh lane
would like to know have you compared
coil to saturn cloud
no i haven't i haven't um not familiar
with saturn
i'm definitely actually going to write
that down because i'm curious
all right next one is from caesar can
you explain a bit more about how the
actual data was fed into the model
and the predicted data was read out of
the bottle on election night
yeah so we actually did this um so
i tried to keep it as simple as possible
and uh you know i mentioned
back in 2014 that i was doing uh
election forecasting for the the dnc
um this was basically a team of uh
five of my data scientists in in a roman
democratic party headquarters
and then a couple dozen people around
the country um
who worked for different firms and state
parties and
everybody kind of gathered together and
entering data and then re-running models
and my less the lesson that i took from
that was i never want to do anything
like that again
um and so for this one i actually kept
it really simple
so you know i brought in the data um
manually
you know literally went grabbed it from
whatever site
i could and saved it um there were some
cases like the census data where i did
use the api
and i just had a script where i went and
pulled it but i wasn't doing that
dynamically i wasn't doing that at the
time of model training
i just wrote a script to call it prep
the data
um so i you know got that done weeks in
advance and then on the output side
um again i i kept it as simple as
possible you know the
the bloomberg folks they had their back
end for the
application they were using but all i
did is i delivered them a giant
csv um or actually i guess three
i had i gave them the i think i gave
them a national forecast sorry three
there was a state forecast
a congressional district forecast and
county forecast
and all of them were csvs and then you
know every
data point for that forecast was a
separate columns there's a column
for the you know upper and lower bounds
of each of the forecasts as well as the
midpoint um
and you know i gave that to them four
days in advance
they got it loaded and so on election
night when we were switching from one
forecast to the other
literally all i had to do was send an
email and said hey switch to the high
forecast
and then somebody on the application
team just re-pointed to a different
column
uh okay that last question was actually
from brent
andrew caesar's real question was andrew
did you consider using
campaign advertising spend on the model
yes
yes um definitely something i was
looking into um this kind of gets to
that
question of comparable data from year
over year
um and this is one where i really
struggled this was
if i had um so i originally specced out
this project around the beginning of
august
but the contract didn't come through
till the end of september but
this was actually one of the data
sources that i had
originally envisioned was fec federal
election commission data
on campaign spending um i wouldn't
probably wouldn't have looked
specifically at advertising
you know rather i think overall spending
would have been a fine proxy
i think there's a few problems with that
though is
one um you know from year to year you
get a lot of variation
in in cost um and it's also a very
non-linear thing so it's a little tough
to figure out how to model that
um there's also just a lot of
complexities around things like media
markets
um so you know depending on whether
you're
say say for a congressional district if
you're in an urban district versus
a rural one um your ad buying costs are
going to be totally different
you know like if you're running for
example if you're running in upstate new
york
for a congressional seat you're going to
be blanketing the airwaves with tv ads
if you're running in you know new york
city you're probably not running any tv
ads
um because you're sharing that market
with 20 or
30 or 40 other congressional districts
um so it really dilutes the impact
so it's a it's a bit tough um also the
other part is simply that
you know this will that would be a lot
of data to wrangle um fec filings are
notoriously
hard to work with and um
you know there's there's certainly data
sets that have been put together by
others
for previous elections um but i'd still
have to go and do that
for you know the present year and part
of the problem too was
um you know a lot of those reports only
go
through um for example you know if i was
doing this in october
i would get the report through september
30th and for all of the previous years
i'd have to go back and recalculate
those
with respect to the same date on the
previous cycles
so at the end of the day it's just one
of those things it could could have been
done but
that was a choice i definitely made for
the sake of reducing complexity
rather than adding it
all right thank you we have another
question from
top tyler potentially a bit speculative
but are there any data sources that you
think
will grow important just a mail-in
voting trend continues or goes
digital post pandemic are there any data
sources that don't exist
that would improve the model
specifically decreased variability
yeah so so mail-in voting is actually
really
really helpful for this um in general
in part because well there's a couple
things one
um you know people who vote by mail tend
to be pretty
consistent um and so
for example you know if you like if
you're somebody who's voted by mail
in the past um you're you're much more
likely to do it in the future than if
you
uh say voted in person that's less of a
solid predictor
um i think the big question is going to
be
whether the trend towards mailing voting
is a uniquely 2020 thing or if it
becomes more permanent because places
like colorado for example that have
switched
over the past decade to all vote by mail
um they've tended to see
you know much more consistent high rates
of turnout um
the problem we had this year was you
know not knowing how to account for the
switch to mail-in voting
excuse me um for the switch to high
rates of mail and voting
because of the pandemic context
excuse me but the other thing i was
thinking about with this is
mail-in voting does give you two
advantages when it comes to prediction
and again
i couldn't take advantage of it this
year because we didn't have good
precedent from previous years
to know how much this was going to
affect turnout but
one is that in order to vote by mail you
need to be registered ahead of time
um one of the tough things for
forecasting uh good for turnout bad for
forecasting over the past couple decades
is the move to same day registration in
more and more states
which is great because it removes a
barrier to voting but it's also tough
because the number of registered voters
is a less valuable signal than it used
to be because
you know back in the day where you had
to register say 30 days out
you at least knew what the denominator
is on the total votes
um and and that's not something you know
with same day voting because or same day
registration because a lot of people
might show up who aren't on the voter
rolls at all that you don't know about
um with voting by mail you know you do
have to be registered ahead of time
and so that does give you a useful
signal not only of the total number but
for any individual
um one of the really helpful things
about a voter registration is it can
tell you
is this person currently located in this
location
on an individual level things like you
know an updated voter registration is a
really important signal
but then um the other thing is you know
you also get
mail-in ballot requests and so you know
if i'm
in most places you know you can't just
print out a ballot online and mail it in
you have to mail in an application they
send you a ballot and then you send that
back in
so we know who's requested and been sent
a ballot already
um and that's a really strong signal as
well and it can tell you both
you know for an individual are they
likely to vote but also just what the
level of
enthusiasm is i think the challenge in
2020 was
you know again totally different context
and especially there were lots of states
that were
there there were some states that were
mailing everybody an absentee ballot
there were others like massachusetts
where they didn't mail everybody a
ballot
but they mailed every registered voter
in application and so they removed one
of the barriers that you previously
had so because of that requesting a
ballot was no longer
the same kind of signal that it was in
previous years um
so that was the kind of thing where
again you know like some of the other
competitiveness metrics
we were seeing signals that interest was
high the problem is
we just didn't have enough precedent to
say how that would translate to some
change in probability of voting or
changing the expected level of voting
and so i couldn't factor into the model
that again is the kind of
reason why we made that forecast that
allowed us to jump up to the high and
historic forecasts
um because we we knew that you know
turnout was almost certainly going to be
higher
than our baseline prediction we just
didn't have a good way to say how much
higher and and
how that might vary from place to place
uh all right excellent we'll give the
last question to drew
do you think this model could be used or
adapted to detect
voter suppression or intimidation
i would be very very concerned about
that and that was something i saw a lot
of problems with
um on election night and and
in the aftermath where um you know a lot
of
a lot of the claims about voting
irregularities
uh often came about because people were
looking at
the um the aps forecasts which most news
organizations were using
and saying hey you know why why do we
have
too many votes or not enough votes like
the numbers don't line up
without recognizing and this is part of
that problem with
the black box model that i was trying to
avoid with
all the documentation people were
assuming that those were actual counts
of balance
and so that somehow the you know biden
plus trump number
didn't match the the total count and
that there was something wrong there
when in fact
those are two separate things it was
just simply that the predictions were
off
and i would be really really nervous to
use this for things around voter
suppression or intimidation
um because you would need something
happening at a massive scale
you know for it to be detectable because
like i was saying with my my model
i expect variation that's plus or minus
five percent
to happen you know ten or twenty percent
of the time
at least um i expect variation that's
you know seven or eight or ten percent
off from the prediction to happen many
places
you know not not a lot of the time but
maybe one percent of the time two
percent
and those so so when those things are
normal
um you would need a massive effect
of voter suppression or intimidation for
it to be meaningful so
you know if i see the model as wrong
compared to the actual
real world results um my takeaway isn't
that there's a problem with the results
my
takeaway is that well that's just the
model being wrong
i think a lot of other data scientists
particularly in politics are really bad
at remembering to have that kind of
humility
but but my first take is always that you
know if the model
and the actual real world data don't
line up um
more likely than not that's the model's
problem not the real world data so
you know in this case i would be a
little hesitant to try to use it for
those circumstances
um i mean you could always use it as a
way to start and i think
going back to that 2014 example um
when i was at the dnc you know we were
using the election night
um incoming data compared to the
forecast
to look for signs of irregularities in
that case for example
um one that we were looking at you know
we it was a county in maryland where we
thought they actually just
had the numbers backwards between the
democrat and republican
because our you know our forecast was
like 60 40
and the results were coming back 40 60.
um
turns out that county just really hated
our candidate
i still don't understand quite why but
like that those numbers were right we
were just off by 20 points
um and we had sent in the lawyers to
literally inquire about this the dnc's
lawyers
which i think was a good use case but i
think it's also a great example of why
um even when you see something as as
seemingly wrong as the numbers being off
by 20 points
you know that happens especially when
you're looking across a large number of
geographies
so i'd be really worried about using it
for that use case
uh all right uh
do any of your you or any other
organizers have anything else to add
not really i just want to thank
everybody for coming and thank everybody
for staying i know we've been going
almost two hours and i see almost
everybody has stuck around
so i'm very excited to see that and and
you know
thanks to you as well and everybody else
who helped organize this
um really great to have more people
contributing